.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Wir haben einen älteren Herren,
der sich umbringen will.
Er trägt anscheinend
eine Waffe auf sich.
Es klingt danach,
als würde er es ausführen.
"Gefahr in Verzug"
heisst das bei der Polizei.
Darum muss es jetzt schnell gehen.
Rüsten wir uns schwer aus?
Wie machst du das? Ja? Gut.
Nimmst du die MP mit?
"MP" bedeutet "Maschinenpistole".
Eine Patrouille ist bereits vor Ort.
Die Situation ist angespannt.
Und dann
plötzlich Entwarnung über Funk.
Ah, super. Ja.
* Sirene *
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Sie haben jetzt
eine Person arretiert.
Sie konnten die männliche Person
stoppen, die sich umbringen wollte,
und in Handschellen legen.
Die Kollegen
bringen den Mann auf den Posten,
wo ihn ein Notfallpsychiater
begutachten wird.
Die Waffe wurde sichergestellt,
die Katastrophe abgewendet.
Das ist der Polizeialltag:
Immer vom Schlimmsten ausgehen,
auch wenn es selten eintrifft.
Ich mache mir keine Gedanken wie:
"Das könnte auch nichts sein."
Man muss
immer von einer Ernstlage ausgehen.
Es ist wichtig, dass man nicht
in eine Art Routine verfällt.
Das kann gefährlich werden.
Es ist Jana Stierlis erste Woche
als vereidigte Polizistin.
Hinter der 23-Jährigen
liegen zwei Jahre theoretische
und praktische Ausbildung.
Jetzt beginnt der Alltag.
Er hat seine Ausbildung
ebenfalls gerade abgeschlossen
und ist auf Nachtpatrouille:
der 26-jährige Nando Wüthrich.
Ein junger Franzose auf einem E-Bike
machte sich verdächtig:
Als die Polizei vorbeifuhr,
wollte er das Weite suchen.
Seine Geschichte scheint den
Polizisten nicht glaubwürdig zu sein.
Ihr Familienname?
- Weiss ich nicht.
Sie kennen den Familiennamen
Ihrer Freundin nicht?
Ich war vorher bei ihr,
aber jetzt bin ich allein unterwegs.
Wissen Sie, ich habe eigentlich
zwei Freundinnen -
eine hier und eine in Basel.
Das Fahrrad gehöre der Tante.
Er habe eine Freundin hier,
wisse aber nicht,
wie sie heisse oder wo sie wohne.
Er habe noch eine andere.
Er sei allein gewesen.
Der Verdacht:
Das E-Bike könnte gestohlen sein.
(Polizist) Das ist ganz einfach:
Kann er nicht belegen, woher es ist,
stellen wir es sicher.
Er soll einen Beleg als Beweis
bringen, dass es ihm gehört.
Dann kann er es
natürlich wieder haben.
Habt ihr den Ausweis und alles
kontrolliert? Alles gut?
Wir werden das E-Bike behalten.
Wenn es wirklich Ihnen gehört,
können Sie in der Schweiz
auf den Posten kommen
und uns die Quittung zeigen.
Dann bekommen Sie es zurück.
- Also wo?
Du kommst auf den Posten
und bringst die Quittung.
Wenn wir sehen,
dass das E-Bike dir gehört,
kannst du es mitnehmen.
Es gibt
ein Sicherstellungsprotokoll.
Das soll er unterschreiben.
So weiss er, dass wir es haben.
So hat er etwas für sich.
Damit soll er kommen.
Das E-Bike wird sichergestellt.
Falls es als gestohlen gemeldet wird,
muss der junge Franzose erklären,
wieso er auf Diebesgut unterwegs war.
Gut, vous pouvez aller.
- C'est fini. Merci.
Seine Personalien
haben sie für den Fall der Fälle.
Er habe zwei Schätzchen,
eine hier und eine in Basel,
und weiss nicht, wie sie heissen.
- Korrekt.
Also, wir bringen ...
- Der Arme hat es streng.- Ja.
Erster Fall vorläufig abgeschlossen,
der zweite wartet bereits.
Passanten
haben den Polizisten mitgeteilt,
dass ganz in der Nähe
ein bewusstloser Mann liegt.
Vermutlich sturzbetrunken.
Ui, ui, ui. Hallo, Monsieur.
Stehen Sie bitte auf.
S'il vous plaît.
Komm schnell. Komm, auf.
Gugus.
(Mann) Oh, sorry.
- Wo wohnen Sie?
Komm. Achtung.
- Lieber hier.
* Lachen *
Bleiben Sie sitzen.
* Unverständlich *
Nein, ist schon gut.
Aber Sie bringen keine zwei Schritte
hin, ohne umzufallen.
Wenn Sie blöd hinfallen, müssen Sie
ins Spital. Das wollen wir nicht.
Sollen wir Sie begleiten?
- Langsam. Hey, langsam.
Bleiben Sie einfach stehen.
- Ja, ja. Alles gut.
Also, guten Heimweg.
Man erwacht besser im Bett
als auf der Strasse.
Ich gehe nach Hause.
- Gut.- Alles klar.
Gute Nacht.
Gern geschehen. Gute Zeit.
Vorsichtig.
- Langsam, bitte. Einfach langsam.
Nicht, dass was passiert.
- Ist gut.
Ei, ei, ei. Um Gottes willen.
* Lachen *
Entschuldige das Lachen.
Das ist nicht meine Absicht.
Der kommt wohl vom Festzelt.
Er war anständig. Das war okay.
Betrunkene
und potenzielle E-Bike-Diebstähle -
auch das gehört zum Alltag
der Polizei Basel-Landschaft.
Vieles ist so ganz anders
als im Krimi,
wo es immer um Leben und Tod geht.
Ein selbst produzierter Imagefilm
soll potenziellen Nachwuchs für
die Baselbieter Polizei begeistern.
Es bewerben sich
zwar jedes Jahr Dutzende,
aber nur wenige sind geeignet.
Ende 2020 hatten sechs Personen
die strenge Selektion geschafft
und wurden im Korps
willkommen geheissen.
Ich begrüsse Sie herzlich.
Ich bin Mark Burkhard.
Ich bin Kommandant
der Polizei Basel-Landschaft.
Ich freue mich sehr,
dass Sie hier sind.
Wir brauchen Nachwuchs.
Wir sind darauf angewiesen.
Es ist nicht einfach,
genügend guten Nachwuchs zu finden.
Wir wollen das Niveau
der Polizeiausbildung nicht senken.
Dementsprechend ist es schwierig,
genügend gute Leute zu finden.
Wir haben ein grosses Interesse,
Sie zu unterstützen.
Ich möchte
eine Vorstellungsrunde machen.
Es nimmt mich wunder, wer Sie sind.
Fangen wir bei Ihnen an.
- Ich bin Nando Wüthrich.
Ich bin 24 und komme aus Blauen.
Ich wohne jetzt in Laufen.
Ich machte ursprünglich das KV,
E-Profil,
und
arbeitete ein Jahr als Buchhalter.
Dann ging ich ins Militär
und arbeitete anschliessend
ein Jahr als Zeitmilitarist.
Dann zurück in die Privatwirtschaft,
Eventmanagement.
Da war ich
die letzten eineinhalb Jahre.
Und jetzt bin ich hier,
um einen neuen Weg zu starten.
Zu meinen Hobbys: Ich treibe gerne
Sport - Fahrrad fahren und joggen.
Ich bin in einer Guggenmusik und
mache seit Jahren Pfadi in Laufen.
Gut. Frau Stierli?
Ich habe Fachfrau Gesundheit gelernt
und anschliessend
diplomierte Pflegefachfrau.
Die habe ich
vor zwei Wochen abgeschlossen.
In der Freizeit
begleitet mich auch sehr viel Sport.
Ich boxe
und bin mit dem Bike unterwegs.
Ich wandere ... Ja ...
Und ich spiele nebenbei Klavier.
Gut, also: viel Spass an
Ihrem ersten Tag. Machen Sie es gut.
Bis bald wieder.
Alle bekommen am ersten Tag
ihre persönliche Dienstwaffe.
Was dürfen Sie
mit dieser Pistole machen?
Sie dürfen sich
zur Notwehr verteidigen.
Sie dürfen Notwehrhilfe leisten,
wenn jemand angegriffen wird.
Und sie dürfen Sie
zur Erfüllung Ihrer polizeilichen
Aufgaben einsetzen,
wenn besondere Gefahr für Menschen
droht, an Leib und Leben.
Vizekommandant - Aspirant Wüthrich.
Bereit zur Waffenübergabe.
Herr Wüthrich,
Ihre persönliche Dienstwaffe.
Danke.
Vizekommandant - Aspirantin Stierli.
Bereit zur Waffenübergabe.
Frau Stierli,
Ihre persönliche Dienstwaffe.
Merci.
Eine Waffe zu erhalten,
ist ein sehr besonderes Gefühl.
Da hat man
eine wahnsinnige Verantwortung.
Ich habe auch einen gewissen Stolz,
dass mir die übergeben wurde.
Ja.
Das Luzerner Seetal.
Hier lassen
die Polizei Basel-Landschaft
und zehn weitere Korps
der Zentral- und Nordwestschweiz
ihren Nachwuchs ausbilden.
2006 wurde hier die interkantonale
Polizeischule eröffnet:
im ehemaligen Lehrerseminar Hitzkirch
und auf dem Gelände
des ehemaligen Zivilschutz-
ausbildungszentrums Aabach.
Etwa 250 angehende Polizistinnen
und Polizisten
werden hier jedes Jahr ausgebildet.
Alle sechs Monate
beginnt ein neuer Lehrgang.
Ende 2020 mit dabei:
Nando Wüthrich und Jana Stierli.
Ich bin schon etwas nervös darüber,
was uns alles erwartet
in den nächsten Stunden.
(Mann) Macht euch langsam bereit.
- Das kommt gut.
Die Grundausbildung
dauert zwei Jahre.
Das erste Jahr
absolvieren sie in Hitzkirch.
Im zweiten Jahr wenden sie das
Gelernte in ihrem Korps praktisch an
und schliessen die Ausbildung mit
der eidgenössischen Berufsprüfung ab.
Der Anfang eines neuen
Lebensabschnittes für Jana Stierli:
vom Gesundheitswesen zur Polizei.
Es ist
eine ganz andere Herausforderung.
Abgesehen
vom Sozialkontakt zu den Menschen.
Der bleibt gleich.
Polizisten lösen Emotionen aus -
auch negative.
Man muss damit umgehen können,
nicht bei allen beliebt zu sein.
So wie ich das wahrnehme,
sind wir vom Grossteil
der Gesellschaft akzeptiert
und es wird als notwendig angesehen,
dass es die Polizei gibt.
Für gewisse werden sie
durch ihre Uniformen zu Reizfiguren,
für andere zu Hoffnungsträgern.
(Mann) Ein stolzes Bild,
wenn man 138 Personen sieht,
die heute an diesem 8. Oktober ihre
Ausbildung in Hitzkirch beginnen.
Herzlich willkommen,
liebe Aspirantinnen und Aspiranten,
zu Ihrem ersten Ausbildungstag.
Der Nachwuchs
soll dafür sensibilisiert werden,
dass er
ab heute unter Beobachtung steht.
Aus Zivilisten werden Polizisten.
Die sollen Vorbilder sein.
Und sie sollen sich
wesensmässig transformieren.
Aus diesen jungen Menschen
will man Wölfe machen,
sagt der Leiter der Grundausbildung.
(Mann) Was ist das Gegenteil
vom Wolf? Jedenfalls in der Schweiz?
(Jana) Ein Schaf.
- Das Schaf.
Wenn es noch Schafe unter Ihnen hat,
müssen wir dafür sorgen, dass daraus
möglichst schnell Wölfe werden.
Der Wolf ist ein Tier,
das viele Eigenschaften mitbringt,
die eine Polizistin
oder ein Polizist auch haben sollte.
Die trifft man auch bei uns an:
Er kommt im Rudel daher.
Er achtet auf andere.
Da sind soziale Gefüge drin.
Er ist auch
stark hierarchisch gegliedert.
Wir wollen,
dass unsere Leute das lernen
und sich entsprechend verhalten.
Jana Stierli wusste schon als Kind,
dass sie zur Polizei will.
Zwei ihrer Onkel mütterlicherseits
sind Polizisten,
einer davon ist ihr Patenonkel.
Ich habe die Inspiration
schon von dort her.
Das hat mich davon überzeugt,
dass ich Polizistin werden will.
Und dass halt
viel mehr hinter dem Beruf steckt
als nur  e i n  Beruf.
Es steckt so viel
hinter dem Polizeiberuf.
Darum wusste ich schon immer,
dass ich das werden möchte.
Sie brauchte
eine abgeschlossene Ausbildung,
bevor sie zur Polizei konnte.
Jetzt darf sie endlich tun,
was sie schon immer wollte:
Polizistin werden.
- Ja, so gut. Komm.
Jawohl, super gemacht.
Der spezielle Anreiz ist,
dass man jeden Tag zur Arbeit kommt
und nicht weiss, was einen erwartet.
Also, welche Situationen
und Erlebnisse man mitnimmt.
Das ist eine Faszination.
Und
in extrem schwierigen Situationen
einen kühlen Kopf zu bewahren.
Die Emotionen beiseitezulegen
in schwierigen Situationen.
Zurück
an der Polizeischule in Hitzkirch.
Wir machen ein kurzes Einlaufen,
damit wir alle warm sind.
Dann sage ich alles Weitere dazu.
Die praktische Ausbildung beginnt
und soll diese jungen Leute
darauf vorbereiten,
dass es auch mal brenzlig werden kann
bei der Polizei.
Dann ist Selbstverteidigung gefragt.
Priorität eins ist: nicht umfallen.
Das ist der Plan.
Wenn der Polizist am Boden ist,
ist das sehr schlecht für ihn.
Wenn ihr zu zweit seid,
helft ihr dem Kollegen sofort auf.
Wenn ihr allein seid,
müsst ihr euch zu helfen wissen.
Genau das trainieren wir.
Gesäss an den Boden ...
... und abrollen. Das ist der Plan.
So schnell wie möglich.
Das Ziel ist, weder Hände noch
Ellbogen zum Abstützen zu brauchen.
Ah, ja. Das nächste Mal
muss ich am Boden bleiben.
Okay, ich versuche es von hinten.
Alles okay?
- Ja, ja.
Okay.
Im Polizeiberuf lässt sich
nicht immer alles mit Worten lösen.
Manchmal kommt es zu Gewalt -
vielleicht irgendwann auch gegen sie.
Ich habe sicher Respekt davor.
Vor der Sicherheit
im täglichen Arbeitsalltag.
Aber ich kann das
nicht richtig beurteilen.
Ich habe noch nie real
im Polizeiberuf gearbeitet.
Ich war immer nur im Schulischen.
Das ist was ganz anderes.
Nächste Lektion: schiessen.
... bevor ich das Magazin reinlege.
Auslösen,
das Magazin runterschieben.
Zwischen
Ringfinger und kleinem Finger.
Ich hole das neue Magazin.
Wiederum
mit den Kriterien der Finger.
Ich setze es ein, schiebe es
nach oben - Kontrollgriff.
Der Umgang mit der Dienstwaffe
fängt mit Manipulationsübungen an.
Laden und entladen - immer wieder.
Lieber langsam,
dafür technisch korrekt arbeiten.
Ist okay? Gut. Wir kommen zum Laden.
Waffe greifen und laden.
Die Handgriffe sollen durch ständiges
Wiederholen zum Automatismus werden.
Die Theorie dazu hat Jana Stierli
schon lange verinnerlicht.
Ob ich im Notfall schiessen würde -
ich denke sicher.
Aber wichtig ist, dass ich vorher
alle Möglichkeiten geprüft habe
und das Verhältnismässigkeitsprinzip
beachte.
Vom Schiesskeller
geht es ins Klassenzimmer.
Ihr seid
mit sehr viel Macht ausgestattet.
Ihr wurdet rekrutiert.
Die Auserwählten, die Polizistinnen
und Polizisten werden dürfen.
Strassenverkehrsrecht ...
Wo gilt es, für wen gilt es
und wo steht das drin?
Die Menschenwürde ist der wichtigste
Grundbaustein der Bundesverfassung.
Ihnen wird
viel theoretisches Wissen vermittelt:
Berufsethik, Recht, Deutsch, Psycho-
logie, Kriminalistik und vieles mehr.
Man muss fahrfähig sein
und, und, und.
Theorie und Praxis verknüpfen,
darum geht es bei dieser Ausbildung.
Z.B. bei "HG" - "häuslicher Gewalt".
Etwa 20'000 Fälle
gibt es pro Jahr in der Schweiz:
über 50 pro Tag.
Was machen wir zuerst?
- (Mann) "Halt, Polizei!" rufen.
Was macht ihr mit ihm zusammen?
Einsatzmittel.
Gewalt stoppen. Einverstanden?
Das ist das Erste. Das ist
der primäre Auftrag: Gewalt stoppen.
Nach der Theorie
die praktische Übung.
(Nando) Oh, hörst du das?
- Ja.
* Laute Stimmen im Hintergrund *
Frau Weidli?
- (Frau) Kommen Sie rein.
Polizei Basel-Land. Dürfen wir?
- Kommen Sie rein. Ja.
(Mann) Nein, was?
- (Polizist) Bleiben Sie dort.
Legen Sie die Flasche weg.
- Nein.
Grüezi, Polizei Basel-Land.
- Ihr habt hier nichts zu suchen.
Du musst raus,
das ist meine Wohnung.
Nein, wir ...
- Weg hier.
Hören Sie bitte auf,
mich anzufassen.
Nando Wüthrich muss versuchen,
den betrunkenen Ehemann zu beruhigen,
der von einem Klassenkameraden
gespielt wird.
Komm, wir nehmen ihn.
- Das kackt mich an. Hey!
Hey, ganz ruhig.
- Meine Weinflasche.
Loslassen.
- Ich muss trinken.
Lassen Sie die Flasche los.
Wenn Sie sich
die nächsten 5-10 Min. benehmen,
können wir darüber reden.
Aber bis dahin,
für Ihre und unsere Sicherheit ...
Habt ihr nichts Besseres zu tun?
Nein, wir sind auf der Arbeit.
Nando Wüthrich
ist der Sohn eines Kantonspolizisten.
Darum hat er schon früh gelernt,
welche Folgen
Verbrechen haben können.
Er sei auch schon
zu schnell gefahren, gibt er zu,
ansonsten habe er aber
eine weisse Weste.
Ich würde mich schon
als korrekten Bürger bezeichnen.
Ich halte mich einfach an die
Regeln, wie das jeder sollte.
Ja, ich gebe mein Bestes.
Nach den praktischen Übungen
in Hitzkirch
geht sein Tag
jeweils im Homeoffice weiter.
Die ganze Theorie muss er sich
wegen der Coronaviruspandemie
zu Hause erarbeiten -
in einer blitzblanken Wohnung.
Ich denke,
dass meine aufgeräumte Wohnung
mich und v.a. meine Partnerin
widerspiegelt.
Wir mögen es einfach beide
gerne ordentlich.
Damit wir wissen,
wo unsere Sachen sind.
Und so ...
Ja, so haushalten wir auch.
Wir achten einfach darauf,
die Dinge wieder zu versorgen,
damit wir sie nicht suchen müssen.
Hallo.
- Hey, Schatz. Hoi.
Ça va?
- Ja.
Seine Freundin ist Heilpädagogin.
War dein Tag gut?
- Ja.
Ich hatte einen anstrengenden Tag.
Für sie passt Nando Wüthrich
ausgezeichnet in eine Uniform.
Er sei der geborene Polizist.
Er hat sicher
gute kommunikative Fähigkeiten.
Er kann sich klar ausdrücken.
Er ist sehr verantwortungsbewusst.
Oberkorrekt.
- Oberkorrekt, manchmal. Nein.
Er ist auch empathisch,
was sicher auch wichtig ist.
Und auch der sportliche Aspekt.
Die hohe Energie,
die er so positiv einsetzen kann.
Seine Freundin sei geduldiger als er,
sagt Nando Wüthrich.
Er könne dafür
besser mit Stress umgehen.
Er bleibe
auch in schwierigen Situationen
immer ruhig,
anständig und natürlich auch sauber.
(Mann) Vorwärts! Go! Go! Go!
- Vorne rechts.
Ist bei dir gut? Okay.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ah, ich auch.
Jana Stierli trainiert heute
für die ultimative Eskalationsstufe.
Vorwärts! Go! Go! Go!
In einem Gebäude
hat ein Amokläufer oder Terrorist
angefangen zu schiessen.
Wer zuerst vor Ort ist,
muss eingreifen.
In solchen Fällen
geht es nämlich um jede Sekunde.
Bis die Spezialeinheit kommt,
ist vielleicht schon alles vorbei.
(Mann) Denkt daran:
Wenn ihr zu zweit unterwegs seid,
verschiebt ihr euch im Team.
Alle schauen über die Schulter.
Macht es immer gleich. Einfach
funktioniert. Alles andere nicht.
Tempo geht?
- (Alle) Ist gut.
(Mann) Eher zu langsam.
Eher zu langsam?
- Du kannst zulegen.
Die angehenden Polizistinnen
und Polizisten
trainieren verschiedene Formationen.
So würden sie im Ernstfall vorrücken.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Das ist sehr eindrücklich.
Vom Theoretischen und Praktischen
her.
Ja, wir mussten uns wirklich
sehr viel aneignen.
Zuerst kommt die Bundesverfassung.
Ja.
Das sind die Kompetenzen
zwischen dem Bund und dem Kanton?
Und ...
- Korrekt.
Genau.
Ja.
Und dann
kommt das öffentliche Recht.
Aber dann
auch noch das private Recht.
Jana Stierlis Freund,
ein Medizinstudent,
unterstützt sie
auf dem Weg zu ihrem Traumberuf.
Die beiden wissen, dass
viele erfahrene Polizisten sagen,
die unregelmässigen Arbeitszeiten
seien eine Belastung
für sie und ihr Umfeld.
Wir haben uns so kennengelernt.
Ich arbeitete vorher
ja in der Pflege.
Dort ist es Gang und Gäbe,
dass man am Wochenende arbeitet
und
Früh-, Spät- oder Nachtschicht hat.
Daher ...
Mein Umfeld kennt das, du auch ...
Ich mache mir da keine Sorgen.
Vorher klappte es ja auch gut.
Ich denke,
es wird weiterhin gut klappen.
Das werde ich
in meinem Beruf auch haben.
Man muss Wege finden,
um darum herum zu arbeiten.
Bis jetzt machen wir das gut.
Wenn sie z.B.
mal Nachtschicht hatte
oder ich bis weiss-ich-nicht-wann
irgendwo war ...
Wenn es halt nicht passte,
passte es nicht.
Und sonst suchen wir Kompromisse.
Wir haben in Allschwil
nach wie vor die EBD-Situation,
mit diesen zahlreichen Einbrüchen
in Wohnhäuser.
Jana Stierlis Praxisjahr beginnt.
Heute geht sie
zum ersten Mal mit auf Patrouille.
Nach so viel Theorie
hat man es irgendwann gesehen.
Klar, die Theorie muss sein.
Aber umso grösser
ist die Freude auf heute,
auf den praktischen Teil der
Ausbildung und auf die Zukunft.
Man könnte meinen,
sie gehe nicht auf Patrouille,
sondern länger in die Ferien.
Ja, schon ein bisschen.
Ich habe gerne viel dabei.
Ich habe
noch mein Verbandsmaterial dabei
und sonst noch ein paar Checklisten.
Ja ...
Vielleicht brauche ich die.
- Das kenne ich.
Schon?
- Die werden weniger mit der Zeit.
Okay. Ja, gut.
Jana Stierli
ist jetzt nicht mehr Aspirantin,
sondern Anwärterin,
die letzte Stufe
vor der Vereidigung zur Polizistin.
Nando Wüthrichs erster Fall:
ein Einbruchdiebstahl.
Diese Wohnung
wurde offensichtlich durchsucht.
Wann verliessen Sie das Haus
am Morgen etwa?
Um 8.30 Uhr.
- Um 8.30 Uhr.
Während Nando Wüthrich
das aufgelöste Opfer befragt,
suchen die Forensiker nach Spuren,
welche die Täter
hinterlassen haben könnten.
Wir wissen:
Die Türe ist abgeschlossen.
Das ist die einzige Öffnung.
Sie waren drin.
Also kamen sie so rein
und gingen so raus.
Durch diese Türe
sind sie eingedrungen.
Nun müssen die Polizisten hoffen,
dass sie eine der gesicherten Spuren
zu den Tätern führen wird.
Das war gut. Perfekt.
Wir haben sie gut abgeholt.
Sie fühlt sich
hoffentlich wieder sicherer.
* Beschwingte Marschmusik *
Schliesslich ist es so weit:
Die zweijährige Ausbildung
ist zu Ende.
Heute werden Jana Stierli
und ihre Kollegen
zu Polizistinnen und Polizisten
befördert.
Ich begrüsse Sie ganz herzlich
zu dieser Beförderungsfeier.
Sie werden
verschiedene Situationen erleben.
Situationen, wo sich Menschen
in einer schwierigen Lage befinden
und Sie ihnen helfen können.
Sie werden aber auch immer wieder
schwierige Kundschaft haben.
Sie werden aber sicher häufig
erfreuliche und schöne Situationen
erleben.
Zusammengefasst: Die Arbeit macht
manchmal Spass, wie andere auch,
und manchmal ist sie auch belastend.
Wichtig ist,
dabei nicht zu vergessen,
dass die Arbeit eine grosse
Bedeutung für die Gesellschaft hat.
Kommandant - Anwärter Wüthrich.
- Polizist Wüthrich.
Nun ist es offiziell: Aus einem
Anwärter ist ein Polizist geworden.
* Applaus *
Kommandant - Anwärterin Stierli.
- Polizistin Stierli.
Herzliche Gratulation.
- Herzlichen Dank.
Gratuliere.
- Vielen Dank.
* Applaus *
* Konzertante Blasmusik *
Jetzt beginnt der Berufsalltag.
In der Nacht von Samstag auf Sonntag
führen sie in einem Tunnel
eine Verkehrskontrolle durch.
Langsam, aber sicher
ist ein Bauchgefühl da.
Es sind meistens
die auffälligen Autos,
die für uns interessant sind.
Entweder
stark motorisierte Fahrzeuge
oder Fahrzeuge
in einem schlechten Zustand.
Und je nachdem,
wenn viele Leute drin sind -
gerade viele junge Männer oder so -,
kann es interessant sein,
sich das anzuschauen.
Dieses Fahrzeug aus Frankreich
wollen sie sich näher ansehen.
Wieso fahren Sie
durch die Schweiz ohne Pass?
(Mann) Vergessen.
- Ich rede mit ihm, einen Moment.
Wer hat eine ID?
Vous?
Es handelt sich um eine Familie:
zwei Söhne und ihre Mutter.
Der Fahrzeuglenker
erzählt den Polizisten,
er habe einen Führerausweis,
nur leider nicht dabei,
aber er könne ihnen ein Foto
davon auf seinem Handy zeigen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Haben Sie den Führerausweis
in Frankreich gemacht?
Ja, habe ich.
Einen Führerausweis für ein Auto?
- Ja.
Wir müssen sicher sein,
dass seine Angaben stimmen.
Das ist das Blöde.
Gib das der Zentrale durch,
um nachzufragen, ob das stimmt:
Name, Geburtsdatum - sie sollen
bei den Franzosen checken.
Das will ich wissen,
sonst lassen wir ihn nicht fahren.
Guten Tag. Ja, es geht gut, danke.
Ich habe da eine kleine Frage.
Es betrifft eine Person,
die in Frankreich wohnt
und durch die Schweiz fährt.
Er hat
keinen Führerausweis bei sich.
Es handelt sich
um einen Mann aus Algerien,
der in Frankreich wohnt.
Die französische Polizei
überprüft die Angaben.
Er hat keinen Ausweis?
Der Mann hat also gelogen.
Er hat keinen Ausweis.
- Ich habe das Foto gezeigt.
Nein, du hast keinen Ausweis.
- Auf dem Telefon.
Du hast keinen Ausweis.
- Ich bin daran, ihn zu machen.
Vous n'avez pas ...
Jetzt hör mir zu.
Du hast die Prüfung nicht bestanden,
du darfst nicht fahren.
Für Sie ist hier fertig,
Sie kommen mit uns.
Es geht ab auf den Polizeiposten.
Ich gehe ins Büro mit ihnen.
- Ja, sehr gut.
Auch die Mutter und der Bruder
werden befragt.
Der Fahrer ist in einem anderen Raum.
Gut 2 Std. dauert das Ganze.
Dann muss er rund 800 Fr. zahlen -
u.a.
wegen Fahrens ohne Führerausweis.
Danach darf die Familie gehen.
Bei Jana Stierli
ist ein Notruf reingekommen:
Ein Tankstellen-Shop
wurde überfallen.
Der Täter ist flüchtig.
Ich schnalle mich ab.
Falls ich die Täterschaft sehe,
könnte ich sofort rausrennen.
(Über Funk) Gesucht
wird eine Person. Er sei geflüchtet.
Ein Mann mit einer schwarzen Jacke
und einer grossen Brille.
Ca. 1,5 bis 1,8 m gross. Schlank.
Er habe eine Coop-Tasche gehabt.
Ja, verstanden. Das haben wir.
Er könnte natürlich
diesen Weg entlang.
Hier unten.
- (Mann) Auf die deutsche Seite.
Zur Tatwaffe: Es habe eine Klinge
zum Ärmel rausgeschaut.
Die Patrouille postiert sich
in der Nähe des Tatortes.
Vielleicht haben sie ja Glück
und der Täter spaziert vorbei.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Nach etwa einer halben Stunde
wird die Übung abgebrochen.
Der Täter
ist wohl schon über alle Berge:
vermutlich über die nahe Grenze
nach Deutschland.
Ich denke, im Laufe der Zeit
lernt man bei der Polizei
damit umzugehen,
dass man nicht jeden Täter
feststellen kann,
dass eine gewisse Täterschaft
davonkommt.
Wir geben alles und versuchen,
unsere Ressourcen
zu nutzen und anzuwenden.
Wir versuchen, damit zu ermitteln.
Wenn wir damit
auf keine Täterschaft kommen,
müssen wir das wie akzeptieren.
Es ist eben nicht wie im Krimi,
das hat sie schnell gelernt:
Im wahren Leben
gewinnen die Guten nicht immer.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023